all right so i i know that by doing this
story i'm gonna get a whole rash of
trolls from the left saying oh my god
david how can you praise barack obama
he's a centrist neo-liberal he's
terrible his drone policy his
deportations and of course
i've criticized all of those things but
that doesn't mean that we can't look at
barack obama speaking at a rally and
realize
wow
the political discourse has really
collapsed over the last five years in
particular as the virus of trumpism has
degraded in course in political dialogue
we can't say wow
that's actually a uniquely talented
political speaker barack obama doesn't
mean we liked what he did with drones or
surveillance
so let's get to it and please don't read
into this segment more than what i'm
actually saying there's a bunch of
important elections next tuesday
november 2nd i'm going to be covering
results live with you on youtube twitch
and facebook starting around 8 pm
eastern on tuesday next tuesday night
one of those races is the virginia
gubernatorial election
now in this race
uh incumbent democratic governor ralph
northam is term limited out so it's a
race between two challengers it's
democratic candidate terry mcauliffe and
absolutely
dangerous right-wing republican glenn
younkin
yunkin is a real lunatic i mean a true
political and cultural extremist
youngkin has made clear his allegiance
to donald trump and trumpism initially
although he's since kind of backed away
because it seems like maybe it's not
going to help him that much yunkan for
months didn't even acknowledge that joe
biden legitimately won the 2020 election
it's it's that crazy of a guy he's
against abortion and he's against gun
safety measures he's really really
horrible the race is tight it's within
the margin of error i could show you
polls oh 1.2 points doesn't matter it's
within the margin of error it could go
either way
so former president barack obama has
been out campaigning with terry
mcauliffe and in a very specific sense
it was really refreshing
not because i like barack obama's drone
policy or whatever
but because barack obama was able to do
something
that often gets lost when we're in the
day-to-day of the current right-wing
insanity and extremism and it's one
crazy thing after another which is
barack obama distilled
just how absurd the modern republican
party and american right wing has gotten
so let's look at some clips in this
first one this is like a classic obama
thing where he hits a bunch of issues
about the hypocrisy of glenn younkin
and he touches on opportunism and other
things he starts with some jokes and
builds into hey guys this is really
serious this is this is like a textbook
two minute political speech excerpt and
you really it really it's interesting to
look at it and see y'all the guy
the guy can hope that's great
i'm less convinced
that
the co-ceo one of the largest private
equity firms in the world spends his
time washing dishes and going grocery
shopping but who knows maybe
but i i i i mean if you do notice that
like whenever uh a wealthy person runs
for office they already always want to
show you what a regular guy they are
so he starts with the jokes and i know
people are saying well obama's rich too
yeah right this is political speech this
is about what are the policies and and
making a connection to that yes obama's
also incredibly wealthy
but that's okay
[Music]
but when your supporters hold a rally
where they pledge allegiance to a flag
that was flown
at the insurrection
at the capitol on january 6th so he's
doing two things here he's starting to
shift from the jokes to the sirius and
he's slowing down the speed and then at
the end he'll build back up but instead
of with jokes with anger that he wants
the crowd to feel with him it's it's
really textbook
hey the the biggest threat
to our democracy
in my lifetime
when you don't separate yourselves from
them when you when you don't think
that's a problem
well you know what
that's a problem
you you can't run ads telling me you're
a
regular old hoops playing dishwashing
fleece-wearing guy
but quietly cultivate support
from those who seek to tear down our
democracy
either he actually believes
in the same conspiracy theories that
resulted in a mob
or he doesn't believe it
but he's willing to go along with it
to say or do anything
to get elected
and maybe that's worse
because because
because that says something about
character
and then now here's the final character
will end up showing
when you actually are in office
[Applause]
what are you willing to stand up for
when are you willing to say no
to your own supporters when are you
willing to say there's some things that
are more important than getting elected
and maybe american democracy is one of
those things
so that that is really well done
political speech you don't have to love
barack obama's politics or whatever
this is a really great technique of
starting with jokes and chuckles
and then you slow down and you start to
get serious and then once you have the
audience with you you then build up to
exactly how barack obama finishes that
into getting people to feel about glenn
younkin the way they should i mean we
should be outraged about this disgusting
guy this is a really notable skill that
barack obama has and whatever your
thoughts are about him we have to
recognize being really good at something
and that two-minute clip is such an
example
of someone that is really at the top of
their field in being able to deliver
this kind of speech in this i'm going to
do one more clip here um in this clip
very concisely characterizing the
right-wing culture war as a phony
trumped up culture war designed to
create outrage i like this just because
it's a great assessment of what we've
been saying for a long time they just
they're not doing policy they're just
trying to get people fired up with these
cultural issues we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped-up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media has peddled to
juice their ratings and the fact that
he's willing to go along with it instead
of talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
that's not what you need virginia
instead of forcing our communities to
cut back at a time when we're just
starting to recover we should be doing
more to support people who are educating
our kids and keeping our neighborhoods
safe so you guys get it a very very
highly skilled political order his drone
program was horrible
the surveillance was horrible i'm with
you i'm with you but uh glad to see him
out campaigning for terry mcauliffe that
this i would say this is the biggest
race on the ballot uh next tuesday if
you live in virginia uh make sure you're
getting out and voting the difference
between terry mcauliffe and admittedly
establishment democrat no doubt about it
versus glenn younkin i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly
could not be more different and we're
going to have live results for you eight
days from today i hope you'll join me 8
p.m eastern eight days from today with
results
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chili sleep which
makes customizable climate-controlled
sleep solutions to sleep better their
flagship products are the uhler sleep
system and the cube sleep system which
is what i have both are hydro powered
temperature controlled luxury mattress
pads you can make them as cold as 55
degrees fahrenheit if you wanted you
could go as hot as 115 degrees uh i like
the cooler option i keep mine at 60
degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you twenty
percent off everything when you go to
chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video